leann rimes gets in the holiday spirit I  love Christmas I grew up like that being  kind of our biggest holiday  tis the season for the country star Lee  Anne tells us she started decorating for  the holidays right after Halloween and  she just released her third christmas  album with the little help from her  stepsons did jake and mason have an  input but did they say hey we want you  to include this on the alley you know  what they did actually Jake he loves to  like sneak in underneath piano where we  can't see him in he'll like he'll pop  out he'd be like I think it should go  like this so yeah he he helped write the  record leanna's kicking off her holiday  tour this friday but she'll be home in  our pajamas for Christmas Eve and  Christmas Day we end up around the piano  most of the time not sober oh yeah yeah  everything sounds really bad by the end  of the night